[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I won't blow this is John's calendar he
bought he's gone right now so I decided
I'm gonna fill in the rest of the
calendar for him find a homeless man and
then go back to Monday with a teen
there's some suggestive things on here
oh my goodness with the dad and the girl
when I contemplate cutting this out but
teaching the little girl to open her
mouth to intake milk like that what do
you call James Gunn when he works out
his glutes
James bun he told us his son actually
loves our channel too so I said why
don't you so what's her son's name and
we'll give him a shout it's cool right
high five what do you call Sigourney
Weaver when she's turned on I said horny
Sigourney everything that's like a bad
thing that be done was done and this
there is a stabbing
there is my tiny person up there - I'm
just stabbing the knife Andy I speak
reading there was a fork feeding the the
flesh to the dog if there's one thing
you have to get credit for just say
I was gonna say you know quality over
quantity instead of just like a bunch of
these people oh my god Greg ah
the worst marijuana experience I've ever
had my my vlog was so high I thought I
was in Gotham City I had to start
imagining Catwoman doing not Catwoman
things but you're like crawling on the
wall this all sounds really cool right
you go home man how cool would it be to
be in Gotham City you got to understand
I'm believing I'm in Gotham City but I'm
not high thinking I'm Batman in Gotham
City I'm high thinking I'm a normal
civilian in Gotham City
I've been genuine this entire letter now
Yusef if you're reading this you have an
amazing loving father but I need you to
stop that reading this right now because
I have to tell your father something
only for adults
yeah or stop watching the video Gareth
you've earned yourself one fat sloppy
fellatio from Gregory Angelo
computer survival on occasions I know
how to love my business that's cool how
long 50 minutes make sure not to go over
now I got home at like 3 3 I heard you I
was watching porn 50 minutes from right
guys if you type in action you've never
seen the Dickie Roberts scene welcome
back to the hot girl right now is live
streaming notice me Jackie Hawaii the
notification for your live stream hey
trio this is raw Q&A this pennis would
don't I know your mom might be watching
so I said pennis oh yeah because she
can't tell cuz your mom is an automatic
who's gonna go picked up the word penis
can't watch video John good
[Music]
but here we go again you bagged yourself
a friend get off the phone my girlfriend
recently I shared this conversation with
her I wanted to share with you guys what
our conversation I had over messages if
you are kissing your girlfriend while I
am still floating in the paint
well you kiss your girlfriend first and
leave me floating in the pee and ignore
me or save me up first and kisses your
girlfriend later